I think we both met Chris Farley around
the same time hmm I remember very
clearly when he came to Saren out live
and he was waiting for an interview with
Lauren I think he had to wait for two
days outside Lauren's office and so I
ended up just clowning around with this
great new guy I'd never met before named
Chris Farley you met him probably
shortly after he was hired for Sarah
Night Live because you knew Lauren
you knew Lorne Michaels so how is that
when you met Chris because I know you
eventually worked with him in Tommy Boy
but you met him I think at Lauren's
house is that committed I met him at
Lauren's wedding and you know how you
there's certain people in life that for
whatever reason you remember exactly
where you were when you met them mm-hmm
and think about many people that we meet
famous not famous and we don't remember
where we met them for the first time or
what they were doing or how they were
standing Farley was one of those guys
probably because he was packed into a
suit that was 17 times too small for him
right and sweating like he had jumped
into Lake Michigan but he was standing
by the porta-potties and and then of
course his first acting job in a movie
was in Wayne's World 2 and then of
course we did tommy-boy together and I
loved him he was funny and he and spade
they would fight over me like I was the
hot girl they were they would get very
jealous of who was spending time with me
and it really made me laugh I understand
that I understand where they're coming
from always I'm always jealous when I
hear that you're spending time with
others one quick farley story is he
loved to eat steak mm-hm and I took him
to a steak house when we wrapped Tommy
Boy and he had two two full bone-in
Porter houses upon each bite of the two
full bone edge porterhouses
he put an entire cube of butter on every
bite and when I was horrified like
Farley you doing he said it needs a hat
oh god bless him yes what a brilliantly
funny guy I've never I've never eaten
steak every time every bite of steak I
eat to this day I go I wonder if I
should put a half on this maybe not
Surgeon General might disagree